Leticia a contacté le grand jury, ce qui a conduit à plusieurs arrestations.
Ce n’est qu’un exemple d'une femme qui n’est jamais allée au lycée,
ni à l'université,
mais qui a trouvé son pouvoir.
En plus, elle a recruté d'autres personnes de sa communauté
pour se porter candidat à une fonction publique.
Vous savez quoi ? Ils ont tous été élus.
À mes yeux, Leticia incarne vraiment
une chose que Coretta Scott King a dit
et que je vais partager avec vous :
« Il n'y aura jamais la paix dans le monde
tant que les femmes ne prendront pas le pouvoir. »
(Applaudissements)
J'avoue avoir modifié cette déclaration pour dire :
qu'il n'y aura jamais la paix dans le monde
tant que les féministes n'auront pas pris le pouvoir.
(Rires)
Parce que nous savons qu'il y a une différence.
Et si nous insistons pour définir ce qu’est une féministe...
une personne qui se bat pour nos droits en matière de sexualité,
pour les droits des immigrants, pour l’environnement,
pour les droits LGBT et aussi pour les syndicats et les travailleurs.
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui a comme implication que les hommes peuvent aussi être féministes.
Pour réfléchir à la féminisation,
il nous faut aussi envisager comment féminiser les politiques,
et pas seulement dans nos grands pays, dans les pays riches comme les États-Unis,
mais partout dans le monde,
notre politique intérieure et étrangère.
Pour arrêter les guerres et avoir la paix, nous pouvons entre autres
garantir que les pays plus riches dans le monde
aident les pays en développement.
On le faisait dans le passé.
Après la Seconde guerre mondiale,
le Japon et l’Allemagne étaient dévastés,
et les États-Unis leur ont consacré une part importante des recettes fiscales
afin qu’ils puissent reconstruire leur économie et leur industrie.
On peut encore le faire
si nous réfléchissons à comment aider ces autres pays.
Voici une illustration de problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés ici.
C'est juste un exemple.
Nous savons qu'aujourd'hui,
il y a beaucoup de réfugiés d’Amérique centrale
à la frontière des États-Unis.
Pourquoi ces gens quittent-ils leur belle maison,
où nous aimons nous rendre quand nous visitons leur pays ?
Parce qu’ils n’ont pas d'opportunités chez eux.
Leurs pays évoquent les bananes pour nous.
Combien de millions de bananes consommons-nous aux États-Unis chaque jour
et partout dans le monde ?
Les agriculteurs d'Amérique centrale
récoltent-ils les bénéfices des bananes que nous consommons ?
Non.
Les bénéfices vont aux sociétés des États-Unis.
Nous pensons que c’est mal.
Si les agriculteurs d'Amérique centrale obtenaient une partie de cet argent
que nous payons pour les bananes,
ils n’auraient pas besoin de quitter leurs maisons.
Ils n’auraient pas à venir chercher asile
aux frontières des États-Unis.
Peut-être alors que beaucoup d’enfants ne seront plus séparés de leurs parents.
Nous savons qu’il y a des pays
où l'éducation et les soins de santé sont gratuits
pour tous leurs citoyens.
Cuba fait partie de ces pays.
Cuba offre des soins de santé à tous ses citoyens,
et l'enseignement secondaire est gratuit aussi.
Il y a 11 millions d'habitants.
On peut donc se poser la question : si un pays pauvre comme Cuba
peut avoir ce genre de ressources, et nous savons que c’est un pays pauvre,
pourquoi d'autres pays plus riches, comme les États-Unis,
ne peuvent-ils pas faire pareil ?
Je pense qu'on peut provoquer ça.
(Applaudissements)
Mais ce ne sera pas possible
tant que nous, citoyens des États-Unis,
et tous les citoyens à travers le monde,
ne nous assurons pas que les politiciens élus dans nos gouvernements
se soucient vraiment de leurs électeurs, de leurs citoyens,
et qu'ils s’engagent à consacrer les ressources à leur disposition
pour leurs citoyens, et non pas pour la guerre.
Alors, comment faire ?
On doit se débarrasser de l’apathie
et impliquer plus de gens.
Nous sommes certains que si la démocratie n'est pas possible aux États-Unis,
elle n'est pas possible ailleurs dans le monde
à moins que le peuple ne s'engage.
C'est pour cela qu'il est crucial que nous fassions entendre nos voix :
« Sortez de votre apathie, cessez de suivre comme un mouton,
et rejoignez la marche pour la paix et la justice.
Faisons ensemble de la vision de Coretta Scott une réalité
pour avoir la paix dans le monde. »
Les élections de mi-mandat ont eu lieu récemment aux États-Unis.
Que s'est-il passé ?
On a vu que beaucoup plus de femmes,
de jeunes, de personnes de couleur, de LGBT,
ont été élus à une fonction publique.
Nous savons que c’est arrivé, pourquoi ?
Parce que beaucoup de femmes ont manifesté.
Il y a eu la marche des femmes aux États-Unis,
et partout dans le monde entier.
On peut constater que nous avons ce potentiel.
Nous avons la capacité de nous débarrasser de l’apathie.
En impliquant tout le monde, en engageant tout le monde,
je pense que nous serons capables de réaliser la vision de Coretta Scott.
Je souhaite simplement rappeler une seule chose
à tout le monde, partout dans le monde,
que nous avons du pouvoir,
que les gens pauvres ont du pouvoir,
que chaque citoyen a du pouvoir.
Mais pour créer la paix à laquelle nous aspirons,
nous devons nous engager.
Alors, qu'en pensez-vous ?
En sommes-nous capables ?
« Oui, on peut ! »
En espagnol, on dit : « Sí, se puede ».
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)